I'm making guides before the video
starts mystic dude check it out it's a
brilliant up for those who want to check
them out now I seek protection from
going astray
well we are all spawns on a day and
night and we all should ask a reminder
to all of us we don't know where we're
going to be when we're going to be
what's going to happen to us this should
keep everybody who's in the Bower seen
not in the tower seen very humble that
those people who are coming in arrogant
ways and looking down on people thinking
you are righteous pious the way you
dress the way you act the books behind
you your folk your beard whatever it may
be you're in a club that you are somehow
saved and you have guided yourself our
says that Allah says Allah Quran indeed
we found weak I did you we found you
lost yeah so this should be a good
reminder to those people out there that
think that they are saved because they
have memorizer of Quran and they know
same thing etc so I'll show you
something
shame time in please who is referred to
when we have our discussions and debates
with the Christians and eighties and
they say to us hold on a second your
Lord is saying that he taught all of
them to prostrate oh there's a
contradiction here was the contradiction
hold on a second he said all the angels
bow before Satan Shaytan wasn't an angel
using this a contradiction no it's not
you know what it is brothers and sisters
this is that the Shaitaan then Shaytan
the Iblees that were talking about was
so righteous but he worship allah
subhanho wa taala everywhere that he
reached the levels and the ranks of the
angels but as he reached that high his
arrogance destroyed him his
self-righteousness destroyed him
so let this be a reminder now point to
but wasn't sisters we have learned a
lesson today we have learnt a lesson
today and why this is not a matter to be
laughing and talking about yeah this is
sad well I shall tell you someone I am
no I don't have feelings they're like a
few number I don't know should I be
upset
sorry angry should I laugh sure
I'm in a mixed emotion I'm a mixed
emotion I fell for this I defended these
peoples honor and while I had you not
regret it because I believed but they
were doing good in a time of Xena I said
at least there's a couple out there
who's doing something good in the hard
way
I fell for it why we assume the best in
the believers the believers that we
fought yeah
so no Chuck Feeny I'm gonna make it very
clear what am i creating you know why
cuz Abdullah has come out and let's
watch this video watch it for yourself
Ali watch it for yourself she's
confessing fru-fru brother moyu may
Allah bless him who's put sleepless
nights into this we're here hours hours
hour for four or five hours which is why
I said we're gonna come back watch it
I just wanna let you all know that I'm
truly sorry about everything and after
speaking to us that way no I'm my family
I've decided that I want to tell you all
the truth I can confirm that the
statement below is the truth about has
an ad saying that he was an agnostic
takeaways to me and his other wives into
believing that we were agnostics to
throughout some parts of our marriage
I'll be clarifying all the claims
you
so you saw there for yourself brother
and sisters she's confessing now I don't
know I'm assuming the best again you
know we have to she claims she's a
believer hundred we take that one and
she claims that she was forced by this
animal by this animal his animal Allah
his animal he is worse than animal I'm
sorry I'm gonna see this you know why
and look for him if he wants to repent
you can do every night right now the
people come first I don't care about him
I'm bitter listen he wants to repair one
like here's the Lord that's the
oft-forgiving most merciful he can turn
to him but I don't give a damn by him at
this moment of time she is saying that
this guy this guy confessing no this
she's confessing but he would force them
force them to leave Islam and what my
brothers and sisters you know we had
this issue couple of months ago of
certain youtubers come in and saying oh
you know why can't Muslim women marry
non-muslim men well maybe this is a
reason why you can't because they force
you mostly it or they may force you into
disbelief like this
Oh Madonna and Sarah yeah the sisters
are bizarre
Sarah and another God knows how many
well she's got seven eight nine ten
wives and other allegations this is a
lesson that crime is messenger when they
say something they know they know why
don't come up here and why can't we
change this the religion is perfected
nothing needs to be changed fathers and
sisters but nothing reminders I want to
give you guys and forgive me if I'm
emotional and I'm angry because it's a
shock because I fell for this these
people have made us all look like
fraudsters like we have to one mind is a
system is a reverse sister who's in me
I'm afraid to put a link up to help her
you know why cuz I don't know what I'm
gonna see I don't think were gonna see
or were you doing with this money well I
I'm afraid this sister isn't mean I know
the sister
personally we can't even go out there do
righteous deeds man we can't even go out
there goes the fear of so whatever you
destroyed and punished everything me and
Mohamed hijab initially can go and check
his videos well assurance but very vital
points as well brothers and sisters
another and I see I want to give to you
guys is the following
well I why is it that we have made the
religion so superficial while my so
superficial Wileman
why why is it socialism everybody that
has a makeup and a beard nfo all so much
thinking you're making something like
it's a Hannibal what is wrong with us
why do we have to everybody that looks
the part
Allah says in the Quran said I'm gonna
have to cook blue Alice isn't gonna
listen carefully both sisters they have
made their oaths in cloak and bed the
way of Allah what they have done is
truly evil that is because they have
believed and then returned to unbelief
so their hearts have been sealed up and
they cannot understand when you see them
that outward from the outward form
appeals to you the outer appearance
abused to you and if they speak to you
you listen to what they say but they are
like propped up plants of wood they
imagine every cry to be against them
they are the enemy so beware of them
Allah Allah fight them how they are
perverted accession accession really the
first self got meat for yourself promise
and sisters everyone you see who speaks
eloquent
everyone you see who says he on eBay -
Erica tawheed Yandy why do we take them
on board like this on Allah and this is
something that you know I'm saying this
what I am saying this cause I genuinely
mean it yeah in my marriage documentary
one night I fell for this show through
something I fell for this why this
sister she looks in this way it she
looks that way she must be righteous
you're gonna learn - documentary fingers
a joke you think I'm giving it to
entertainment I went through hell
I had read - in the hard way now I'm not
seeing not a niqab of the beard mascara
no we're here to preserve the image
these people misused it these people
portrayed something they were not they
were like one African a the enemies of
Islam one why that's why the we are told
that they're gonna be in the bottom of
the Hellfire why because a catheter this
believer we know what is from their
parent we know this kinds of disbeliever
and accession we're talking about
enemies yet we know the guy doesn't like
us okay
the manaphy could look you can't
distinguish how can you distinguish see
you don't know that's why they the
biggest danger to Islam and that's the
reason why they're gonna be in the pits
of the Hellfire brothers and sisters
learn a lesson from this and you know
what when they're just going to do a
little temporary solution to a youtube
video and after that let go no we are
going to be working with Rafa Marino
admit that it mattered Institute and
we're gonna make sure this doesn't
happen happen again we are going to have
a body that regulates
also some public figures they have tuned
up you know I hate Jim see you go and it
says oh is this HMC the chicken Hollande
yes this is going to be done so why so
it preserves the amount of people so
people can't think I can just come and
we Muslims roll out our hearts are so
soft but other sisters well I know how
you're feeling
you fell for this and your fingers you
saw how stupid am I I'm question wrong
so I'm thinking honey you just wanted
the best there was a time of Zener and
you thought this couple is doing good
and I put it out there for you guys I
would never endorse anyone again I would
never endorse anyone again brothers and
sisters well why he must be Bank he fell
for this he fell for this guy come in
and try David Koechner and get fat our
and polygamy he's made pretty what
polygamy
this guy's not has no idea this guy was
doing all kinds of madnesses what my I
swear I swear Panama Panama Tyler the
rub of the cabin one lie I've seen with
my own eyes on one why he'd be like I've
seen my own ears may Allah curse me
destroy me if I'm lying we cannot
produce the video unless the permission
is given however while I belong with you
like a job is here we are believers and
we have witnessed this guy claiming with
his own tongue with his own mouth that
he is an agnostic or he was an agnostic
but his own mouth anybody that comes to
me and says he was an agnostic while
he's doin rukia why was raised in front
of the people I don't care about
anything anymore what that means Tim is
very simple the money that you raised
before was it good
where is it good I'm doubting everything
any move that you make up doubting
there's no more good excuses and really
to me perfume if you think I'm touching
your finger I'm asking simple as where
did that money go number two he was a
assaulting his wife or his wives forcing
them there are text messages of this guy
glorifying saying yes we made you a
disbeliever no can we please see our
island what kind of an English a tan are
you that you're forcing your other wives
to go to this belief and you're
celebrating your celebration one wild
enemy of Agra and you would be our enemy
remove tree like an enemy and I'm not
asking anyone to go and harm you in any
way shape or form but we're just saying
that were lucky if you have a please yes
and what like we have our Lord yeah and
why you you have been exposed and almost
exposed you
pent well you know what light you know
what we I wouldn't forgive you I
wouldn't forgive you but you have a
lower that's the most merciful
yeah if it was us it's a different story
but you have a lord that one light is
there a murderer i him yeah
turn your repentance change your ways
and what you've done what you've
oppressed people how people trusted you
you made us people who and the bowels
you mother we're not perfect let me make
it very clear we have a short force we
are sinners yes we'd seen as well but
what line they were not perverted to
that level
I'm didn't I would have perverted to
that level and we ask a lot to protect
us brothers and sisters in shall I
forget the permission we will play that
video inshallah inside if not there's
the rights we cannot say nothing to that
and we will stick by our word because if
you want one like we was we move seen it
well my believing me in a job who's seen
this class to come up one why he we
honor the family whoever's involved
accession go into detail that they did
not want to share and we will honor that
but but our loyalty is what the Quran
and the Sunnah and the Muslim mean and
with this is what we're gonna do so for
promise it is out there
do not let this affect your Iman you
should be more firm you should be more
firm because you should say you know
what this clam is being a check
reference center and what la he they
will never succeed and then never was
sixteen this shows their desperation
that they come in and trying to
infiltrate I'm not going to do much T so
I'm gonna leave it all above the sisters
may also Hannah wants Allah bless you
guys and know very well that I fell for
it and online I just wanted goodness I
just said they're doing something good
may Allah forgive me and well I people
know I don't and it's not something I
can repent for because I didn't I didn't
know where soon the best just is you
guys you've seen the video you've heard
it for yourself this sister is well may
Allah forgive her for living a double
life etc what happened she's a scoffs
not forgiven and inshallah they can move
on from this and I believe you know they
are all guilty in their own way I'm not
gonna smoke all and give one but this
guy anyways anyways brother and sisters
once again forgive me for my passion and
I think I deserve that
yeah I need a bit of letting this out
we've been here for hours hours were
like going through its stomach we not
emotional I feel like this after that I
know we when again that's what I was
silent that's what I was silent so
- etana inshallah well mine we do not
fear these people and if they think has
an ad and whoever you and who is behind
you while and do not care
do you know if I'm gonna finish I've got
nothing to lose and I've got nothing to
hide
yeah you wanna come come yeah if you if
you want don't try to threaten behaviour
what light repent and turn to your Lord
I'm gonna leave that bad may have a
bless you guys go on sisters go and read
so I'm gonna [ __ ] this is what you
need to do go and wrestle I'm an African
because there's some things we need to
learn that about outer appearance and
we're falling for this not anymore
in Shabbat and sisters and honor the new
hobby sisters and one of the brothers
who observe their beard and the for
exceptional do not let this because this
was the objective for you guys to hate
them to come and see the niqab as a
perverted thing and the builders and
beard as perverted people no no no no no
no no we will preserve that insha'Allah
may Allah bless you guys
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to do not forget to check he drives
video as well and upcoming videos of
what's happening step by step as
evidences come we were bringing it